There's definitely a trend,
which I had not a word I love to use,
but it's,
there's definitely a move,
let's say towards,
you know,
people,
people that are thoughtful about their
space and their interiors are now even
being thoughtful about,
you know,
sort of the,
the,
the amount of,
uh,
you've sort of,
you know,
chemicals are putting into their space
or amount of,
you know,
just the,
the surfaces and what they're made out
of and off gassing.
And um,
you know,
volatile organic compounds is what
people are thinking about.
Um,
and so when,
when someone says something's low voc,
that's what,
that's what voc means.
And um,
you know,
generally when we think of,
um,
you know,
uh,
environmentally friendly interiors,
I,
what I'm used to seeing are these very
kind of like a very sparse,
very kind of clean,
very,
um,
you know,
I call them,
hemp world kind of interiors and,
and they're cool and I actually love the
look of that very minimal.
But one of the things that we were
discussing with the client that a,
I designed this apartment for in,
in River House,
in New York City,
was that,
um,
environmentally friendly interiors don't
have to necessarily be anesthetic,
they need to be your aesthetic.
And even going back to what I was
talking about before,
where,
you know,
my,
I,
I try to design spaces that are very
personal.
So the idea was that I wanted to do an
interior designing interior that was
filled with a,
the personality of,
of the project for the client and tells
her story,
but does it in an environmentally
friendly way.
So this,
the photograph you're looking at right
now,
um,
of this living room,
uh,
this is the living room at river house.
It was all every single piece of
furniture from the curtain hardware,
recycled metal.
The dining table was recycled,
zinc and paperstone top,
uh,
the chairs were in.
They were,
uh,
they were made from all the furniture,
the coffee tables that are all made from
certified woods.
Uh,
they're,
you know,
uh,
with,
with low voc finishes on them.
Uh,
the rug was made from a vintage claims
that were tattered and worn that we cut
up and then we connected them locally
with a organic,
uh,
felt and then put them on organic pads
and the finishes,
the or the glues for the wall covering
were low voc,
the wallpaper's themselves or
sustainable,
it was just the fills for the furniture
are organic.
It just,
it,
you know,
at every level we basically measured how
green,
you know,
I always talk about it being shades of
green and we took and said,
okay,
how can this piece be?
Some things are more green than others.
Um,
and you know,
the lamps that flank the sofa are made
from a vintage wine bottles that are
sitting on certified a walnut plants
with handmade twine,
natural twine,
uh,
um,
lampshades locally made,
the,
the light fixture over the dining table
is made from recycled jet engine parts.
The light next to the dining table,
there's a pair of floor lamps that are
made from a recycled plumbing parts.
So there's an element at,
at almost each piece has a,
a real sort of lineage.
Uh,
you know,
that that connects it to being
environmentally friendly.
But overall I think when you walk into
the space,
you wouldn't look at this and think,
oh,
this is definitely ecofriendly interior.
It just feels like,
I think an interesting space that's kind
of fun.
It's sexy,
it feels fresh,
it feels stylish.
I think that it employs taste to a
certain level and I guess that's
subjective,
but I do think that it,
you know,
it,
there's,
there's a balance.
Uh,
there's,
you know,
all of the elements that I think,
sort of a defined what's,
what,
what is tasteful or pleasing to the eye.
I think it employs a,
those,
um,
those elements.
So I think it's,
you know,
I think it's a very well rounded space
and I think when you look at it,
um,
you know,
it,
it evokes emotions that I hope are
positive and I talk about it in my book
or you know,
about the things that I look for it,
I,
that I put that are sort of incorporate
into all of my designs.
I want them to be fresh.
I want them to be inviting,
I want them to be unpretentious.
I want them to be stylish.
Uh,
I want them to be sexy.
I want them to be inviting.
I want,
you know,
so you're,
you're at every,
you know,
every interior and some,
some depending on the spaces or the
client or the situation are more fun
than sexy or more comfortable or less
comfortable or less inviting,
more inviting,
but they have to be there at some level
and,
and represent and be part of the
collective.
And I think that,
you know,
that ultimately that balance and how you
balance that,
those emotions are really what,
what kind of defines how people
emotionally connect with a space.
And I think that is what that emotional
connection is.
What people are.
You use the term taste in,
you know,
in,
in terms of,
you know,
relating that experience.
One of my favorite interiors in New York
and um,
it is,
uh,
the four seasons restaurant.
I love it because I think it,
it,
you know,
it's just,
it's glamorous,
it's fun.
Um,
it is definitely,
you know,
the moment,
if not the week it was timed,
you know,
based on interior.
Um,
it just,
you know,
it's a,
it's a very cool.
It was cool from the beginning.
It's been cool ever since.
It never,
it's just always been an interesting,
fabulous space and design and when I'm
in,
when I'm in there I feel,
you know,
my emotional reaction to it as like,
I just think it's,
I think it's really awesome.
So I think in,
in New York that's one of my favorite,
uh,
interiors I would say my other favorite
interior in New York as my apartment,
I think you have to really like your
space.
I think you have to really be
comfortable in your space.
You should really like,
and they should always be kind of
challenging,
you know,
and adding and it should always
organically be evolving.
Um,
but I do like my space.
and I think you always,
you know,
you could fall in love with so many
interiors.
Um,
and,
and a lot of times it's not even just
the whole,
the whole space,
it's just you can fall in love with
pieces in and think that's a really
interesting concept or idea and sort of
put that in your,
you know,
kind of like your,
your,
your file cabinet of good ideas.
Um,
I would say God through the world,
um,
I mean the US,
there's enough.
I,
I would,
you know,
New York City is such an international
city.
So there's,
so,
there's so much.
Um,
there's so many influences,
which I think is really fabulous.
I would say as a city,
I love Chicago because I think it's an
amazing American city and the
architecture is really incredible.
Um,
I think it's a great representation of,
you know,
I always say when people come to us and
they say,
Oh,
I love New York first time here,
I say,
well,
you know,
this is like an international city.
Chicago is a true example of an American
city,
I think,
or the best example of an American city
that Philip Johnson's glass house I
love,
but I have to say on the property,
I also love the old farm house on the
same property.
It's,
that's a difficult question for me.
I mean,
I think that,
you know,
worldwide I would say some of my
favorite interiors are very humble
spaces,
um,
that are really not designed in.
There were kind of reaction to,
you know,
making,
making things work.
You know,
I've spent a lot of time in Greece,
the Greek islands,
and you know,
a lot of my favorite,
uh,
spaces are really just kind of very
simple,
very clean.
I'm open and kind of utilitarian at a
certain level.